[Music]
now i would like to invite
dr debo jyoti chakraborty from csir igib
india
they came up with an innovative
diagnostic test for kobe 19
and named it faluda faluda is
a fictional detective character from
india
let's hear more from them about his
innovation
take it away dave hello everyone
my name is uh devo jyoti chakravati i'm
a scientist
working at csir institute of genomics
and integrative biology
in new delhi and i'm very happy that i
have been
given an opportunity today to present
before you some of the work
that is going on in my lab
in the field of crispr casting
technology and particularly
in the in the way that we have been
using
uh this technology for sars covid
detection so today i'm going to talk to
you
a little bit about how we have
repurposed the crispr
diagnostics for detecting sarcoid in
patient samples
i will start by introducing you to the
the major detection mechanisms or the
major
techniques that are being used currently
for
scovic 19 detection and as you can see
broadly
these can be divided into two major
tests
one is uh based on nucleic acid
amplification
where one is trying to detect the
the viral genetic material directly so
it kind of gives us
an impression whether the patient is
positive
at that current time and the second one
is an antibody test
in which a previous infection to the
virus
is detected in the in the by the
presence of antibodies
that the body has generated against the
vital proteins
there is also a third test which is
called the antigen test
in which the test tries to detect the
presence of viral proteins within the
the serum over the the plasma
now on the right side you see
that how these tests are generally
performed and in general the molecular
test which
involves nucleic acid detection relies
on identifying the viral nucleic acid in
this case the rna
making several copies of this rna
after converting it into a dna which is
called the complementary dna
and then the gold standard test which is
called the quantitative pcr test
actually uses a very sensitive probe
which is fluorescently labeled
to specifically bind to a sequence in
the viral
cdna and then emit a signal and this is
generally the gold standard test
in the case of antibody tests or
serological tests
the antibodies in the blood that have
been
that have been generated due to the
exposure to the virus
is detected on a lateral flow device
as you can see on the on the bottom
now both these technologies are widely
used uh
and they have their own advantages and
disadvantages
while the antibody tests uh do not talk
about
the immediate infection it does tell us
important information about the
population
in general and helps in taking policy
decisions
but the nucleic acid amplification test
or the rtpcr based approaches seem to be
the most
suitable to identify patients who are
currently
affected and then quarantining them
ah they of course use the quantitative
rtpcr
probes and a dedicated instrument which
can detect the fluorescence coming out
of this qrt
uh pcr reactions and hence
they although they are very useful and
sensitive
they need the presence of a dedicated
instrument
which can actually do this kind of
experiments and
ah in a lot of low cost settings or
in a lot of developing countries such
kind of instruments
are not available so keeping all this in
mind
we thought of actually using a crispr
based test
which would not be
[Music]
needing such kind of a dedicated
instrument and can be done
at a much more cost effective manner
so crispr is of course precise simple
and robust and
why these properties are a
characteristic feature of crispr is
something that i'm going to tell you
in the next few slides um
it would not be possible to talk about
how we came up with the idea of crispr
if i don't introduce a little bit about
the work that we generally do in the lab
ah because the development of this
fellow the technology
in which we are actually detecting
sarsovic uh
is uh something that has been a kind of
offshoot from
work that we have been doing in the lab
for the last two to three years
on sickle cell anemia and correcting the
mutation for sickle cell anemia using
crispr gas name
so on the left you see a cartoon showing
how a
gas line complex remains bound to dna
and the blue uh nucleotide sequence or
the blue
part of the cartoon actually tells about
a guide rna
which complexes with cas9 and then opens
up
dna double helix which is shown as the
double helix at the bottom
and then it base pairs and it if it base
pairs completely then there is a double
double-stranded
dna break which is then repaired by the
cellular machinery
to give rise to different outcomes of
repair
if the repair happens in a kind of a
quick and dirty fashion
then there are deletions and insertions
that happen
if it happens in a very precise manner
then a specific dna sequence can
actually be integrated at the target
now off-targeting and double-strand dna
breaks of course convolute gene editing
for therapy this is pretty well known
and this happens because the 20 base
pair of homology
that the guide rna tries to find on
target dna
might exist partially at different parts
of the genome
and these sites can also be equally
bound and therefore there can be a
possible editing happening
and the research all around the lab
around the world sorry
over the last few years have been to how
to develop better editors for therapy
it seems there are two you know major
ways by which one can do this
one is to actually engineer the existing
ones
uh and that is why by substrate linked
evolution
or by you know rational design etc a
large number of evolved gas lines or
engineered gas lines
have been have been described
alternately one can look at nature
and try to see if there are cas9
proteins which might actually perform
better
than the the existing ones and these are
also
uh cast lines that have been
characterized
so we have been working heavily like i
said and
the the work that i'm going to show you
is actually done in collaboration with
my colleague dr shovik maithi and we
have been working heavily
as a part of the csr sickle cell anemia
mission to
try to find out proof of concept methods
to correct this the sickle cell anemia
mutation in indian patient derived
stem cells and
to cut a long story short our results
were published last year in pns and
what we did is that we extensively
characterized
an orthogonal cas9 from france's
lanovisida
uh and used it to correct the sickles
and mutation in patient-derived
ah induced peripheral stem cells now
this
ah is an important slide because it
tells you
that this particular gas line had some
very interesting properties
which were later on went and used for
the purpose
of crispr based detection if you look at
this
casino complex carefully you will see
that the
the protein uh the part with which it
interacts with double stranded dna
also circled as a in in the dotted
circle
ah is highly electropositive in nature
it has a high positive charge which
actually renders
this gas line uh into a kind of uh
it it basically makes the cas9 switch
off from its binding state
to a non-bound state whenever there are
mismatches that it encounters in that
dna rna heteroduplex
and this is a very peculiar phenomena
since similar kind of activities not
seen
for even high fidelity gas lines which
have been engineered
meaning that this cast line from francis
illinois sita
is highly specific in the way with which
it interacts with its substrates
and this was our major finding what we
obtained from that
uh from this study and we thought that
we can
actually use this principle of binding
to a target
or disengaging from a target with high
specificity of precision
uh in in developing a detection tool
so crispr based diagnostics uh
and innovative solutions for for
genotyping is not something new
it has been invoked since 2016-17 when
the first papers
uh describing cast 12 and cast 13 uh
came in was was reported
and a number of companies in the past
have been
actually started to to look into the
possibilities of using a crispr
based detection approach most of these
uh
crispr systems or the cast 12 or the gas
13 systems
uh use a trans cleavage activity of
reporter molecules
when the substrate is bound by the gas
12 or the gas typing proteins
we decided to call our system as fn cas9
editor linked uniform detection essay or
feduda
you know we have already have a sherlock
and a detector system which has been
reported
and these are detectives so the name was
inspired by a detective figure
from uh indian uh from an er it's a
fictional indian detective
made famous by the uh author and
and movie director satyajit iii
so how does feluda work so fellow the
works on the principle
that if you have an fn cas9 protein
which
uh like i said uh previously has a very
high specificity to its targets
uh both in terms of how it binds
and also in terms of how it cleaves the
substrate after binding
once this cas9 protein actually
interacts with its target
uh if it encounters more than one
mismatch
then the cas9 actually evicts from the
target
the net result is that there is no
binding or cleavage
however if there is a complete match
or at least one mismatch in the bubble
that you show on the on the left uh
top then the outcome is that there is
binding and cleavage
and we figured out that these outcomes
can actually be represented
ah in different uh formats one is by a
simple
in vitro cleavage reaction in agarose
gel which can also be represented as a
capillary electrophoresis
peaks alternately if one finds a way by
which the cas9 protein can be tagged
with the fluorophore
then the presence or absence of the cas9
protein in the
in the supernatant can give rise to a
fluorescent readout
and finally a lateral flow readout can
also be obtained
by ah developing a chemistry
for paper-based detection so
we took the example of the sickle cell
anemia mutation
and as you can see the wire type
represents a normal blood cell and the
sickle cell
uh the blood of course gets sickled and
interestingly this is caused by a point
mutation in the beta globin gene
and the presence of the mutation is
shown in red
the gag which is getting converted into
a gtg
so we design guide rnas with
keeping this mutation at the second
position intact
uh the guideline is of course reverse
complement so therefore is there is an a
and then we walked along the whole
length of the guide rna
and we found a position which would be
a two and the sixth base bear mismatch
with the target where it would produce a
completely
opposite readout on an agarose gel
cleavage reaction
where the wire type substrate would be
almost completely cleaved
whereas the sickle cell substrate would
be almost not cleaved at all
and this diametrically opposite
phenomena of
negotiating with the substrate uh was
something that we
wish to take forward and use as a
readout
so this was a format in which you can
actually see it directly on a agarose
gel
but we questioned ourselves that this
format of cleavage
was it also faithfully being replicated
in terms of binding to the substrate
meaning whether the cas9 was not bound
to the y type substrate with two
mismatches
and was bound to the signal synonymous
substrate with a single mismatch
and we observed that this was indeed the
case
when we did a single molecule by binding
experiments this is
uh this is a bulk uh molecule study
actually using um
fluorescence mst or micro scales
thermophoresis
we found that whereas a point mutation
or a single mismatch
uh remains you know the cas9 remains
bound to its target
with a relatively strong binding energy
the the kd is 187 also
if one introduces a second mutation then
the binding is extremely weak or not
existent
uh and it becomes high micro molar range
so we figured out that this can be
utilized in a detection scheme
where if you would tag the cas9 protein
with a fluorophore
and you would label the targets with
biotin by putting biotinylated pcr
primers
then bound cas9 proteins would
not would mean that the supernatant
would be devoid of such
fluorophore particles and therefore
would have a lower signal
whereas unbound gas proteins would be
present in the supernatant
and would be detected by a detector
and in this way using fluorescence one
would be able to distinguish
whether a substrate has a point mutation
or not
as is shown in the right
what we also figured out was that
the nature of cleavage or the nature of
binding was happening stoichiometrically
meaning
that if 50 of the molecules
had a point mutation and 50 did not we
would have
50 of these molecules being bound by a
gas protein
and getting cleaved whereas the
remaining 50 would not
to understand this if this was happening
robustly
we and this was the we we actually did
this in
the case of sickle cell anemia patients
and carriers who are heterozygous for
the mutation
and the pattern is shown on the left
here
where you see that the y types is not
cleaved
the heterozygous is cleaved half off
and the homozygous is cleaved nearly
completely
and this is not just happening as a
one-off uh
event in some cases but we did a blinded
study with
at least 50 different samples from a
village in raipur
and the sangha sequencing was done in a
different lab and fellow the detection
was then
done at in our lab and we found
a hundred percent concordance between
the two results suggesting
that this method of identifying carriers
is highly robust
finally we figured out that this two and
next
six mismatch positional identity with
respect
to a proto-spacer adjacent motif or a
pam
would limit our detection ability
or in terms of the number of possible
mendelian disorders we can target
because not all s ps would have a
pam in the vicinity so by putting a pam
uh site in the biotinylated primer
itself
uh one can actually trick the cas9 into
believing that
there is a pam within the amplicon and
in this way
one can actually target all possible
single nucleotide polymorphisms in dna
rna
that is present in the genome we showed
how this works in
gastric biopsy samples containing
variants of helicobacter pylori
and as you can see over here these
variants are different from the normal
helicobacter pylori by just one or two
nucleotides
however they have a different antibiotic
resistant properties to refrigeration
and doctors
generally are not able to identify these
unless they take a scrape
from the stomach and then they culture
the bacteria and after two to three days
they are able to identify if there is an
antibiotic resistance
variant or not failure can do all this
within two hours
so that really reduces the time for
diagnosis
as well as for effective treatment
finally ah this is not just limited to
the lab
we took felloota to a village in
a primary health center as you can see
in rhipur
and in india these kind of
initial tests to identify sickle cell
patients or carriers
one does what is known as a solubility
test which is a very crude test but it
gives a kind of an
quick and dirty outlook whether there is
any kind of uh mutation
present however it's a very
unpredictable and
often inaccurate test and what we also
saw for the
that you know this requires the presence
or the the need to prick blood or to
break the
brick the finger tip and get some blood
and if you look on the right picture uh
on the right uh
side there are these uh students who are
very young students and some of them are
looking with not such a very
enthusiastic face
thinking of how the blood would be taken
from
fraud in order to do the solubility test
so what we came up with idea was to have
a method by which these children could
be asked
to simply spit into a small tube and
then
there would be reaction components
present within that tube
which would isolate the dna from the
saliva
just by leaving on the benchtop for some
amount these are classical molecular
biology
methods and then this can be a substrate
for the feluga reaction
so making it also possible to do this in
a completely non-invasive
manner and
uh as a final step for developing the
falooda
we wanted to make something which would
be
almost be possible to use uh at home
such as a pregnancy strip and one can
actually use a fellow the assay on a
similar kind of a strip to detect the
outputs
so to do that we took help of a
commercial strip
in which there are these zones that are
marked in different colors
and the bottom more zone contains an
anti-fan antibody conjugated with gold
nanoparticles
so if a sample has got a famine in it
fam labeled then the antibody antifa
antibody gold nanoparticles
uh interact with that and it takes the
the sample up the strip and then
if that sample also contains a biotin
label uh then there is a streptavidin
band which is
shown on the extreme right with the very
dark dark red
area this chapter within ah biotin
reaction gives rise to a signal there
whereas if the substrate did not contain
a streptavidin
then the entire complex moves up and
there is a control band
region where a control line will be
formed which tells if the strip has
worked fine
so we uh you know we had to
bring in the fam at some point in the
crispr complex and also make sure
that our substrate was going to be
labeled with biotin
this we managed to do by doing a pcr in
which
the primers were biotin labeled and in
order to make the cas9 rnp fam labeled
we made a chimeric guide rna where the
tracer rna sequence was now going to be
labeled with fam
whereas the crna remains intact without
a label
and we systematically you know figured
out what would be the optimal length of
the crn tracer and overlap because this
was a new cache system
and we found that a 19 nucleotide
overlap would retain the properties
of gasoline rnf complex formation on a
target
and using that we could go down
to almost femtomolar levels of
concentration
and was able to detect even a single
nucleotide polymorphism
by the presence of a band on a strip
so this was where we were at the
beginning of the year and we thought
that you know we had a nice
method by which we can detect single
nuclear polymorphisms but of course then
covet 19 struck
and life turned upside down for a lot of
us
and we quickly realized that you know
this fellow the assay
can be also very useful for detecting
the covin-19
pathogenic sequence and we
developed a technology around that where
the samples that are collected and the
rna
is extracted from the samples and on the
step 3
can go into a single step rt pcr
reaction
now the rt here actually stands for
reverse transcription reaction not the
real-time pcr
so this means a regular pcr instrument
or regular pcr machine
can serve the purpose and the reverse
transcription pcr is done
using two probes two primers
which are biotin labeled and this is
followed by the lateral flow assay
in which the family build ah
cas9 rnp complex is targeting 20
nucleotides
of of the viral rna sequence in that
amplicon
and if it finds that then there is a
positive band if it doesn't find that
then there is a negative this has three
layers of specificity because
we use uh first a reverse biotin label
primer specific to
a covated gene then there is a forward
primer which is also specific to that
same covate chain
and finally the high specificity of fn
casino rnp
towards that uh amplicon 20 basis in the
templicon
uh the entire process can be done within
an hour it is economical because it
doesn't use
the fluorescent tachman probes which are
the costly element in a quantitative pcr
and it also has a semi-quantitative
flavor which i am coming to it in a
minute and there is no requirement of
specialized equipment
just a simple pcr machine which is
present in
schools and universities in healthcare
settings can be used
and as you can see uh this is a slightly
older slide
uh the starting rna amount uh to put it
into
uh rough estimates one can detect
starting up till 10 copies of a target
rna
and ct value is almost going up till 40
ah using a feluda detection and
about an hour it takes if one uses the
single step cdna preparation and a
normal pcr if one uses an
rt rpa or isothermal way of developing
uh
amplicons then this entire process can
be brought down to about 30 minutes
and at a lab level this costs roughly
about 600
rupees in the indian rupees
and the final readout looks a little bit
like this there is a positive control
which pro
gets a band and the sample whereas a
negative control in a negative sample
will not have any of these bands and
this happens by lateral flow so if you
put these strips in it
in a in a pcr tube within
a couple of minutes as you can see on
the left most uh
on the strip there is the control band
developing first on the top
and then you can see the test band
developing at the bottom
so it's a pretty rapid test
and we also developed an ai app uh which
we call as top shape for uh you know
people who have read satyajith
novels uh on failuda they know that
feluda is often assisted
by his cousin who is called and a third
friend who is called jet are you
so our ai app was called tokushi which
is true outcome predicted by strip
evaluation
which can be used to take a picture of
the of the
strip and then it does background
correction
normalization with the ntc control and
then can give a readout
based on the training on machine
learning done over several several
hundreds of samples
what is also important to understand
here is that you know the failure
reaction happens by stoichiometric
binding
which means that every molecule of the
target is bound by a molecule of f and
casino
so if there are 50 molecules there would
technically be 50 molecules of gas line
binding
and there would be a corresponding strip
intensity so we found
that the there is a pretty high
concordance between the qpcr
uh and ct values and the phil the
intensity a low qpcr ct corresponds to a
higher fellow the band intensity
giving it a semi quantitative flavor so
uh
one can detect whether a patient is
highly positive for covet 19
versus a patient who is probably just
you know recovering with a very low
weak intensity this is slightly
different from how
the catch 12 and the cash 13 waste
systems work where there is a charged
cleavage activity
resulting in a lot of fluorescence
signal even from
lower number of uh viral copies of
course it
has the advantage that it amplifies the
signal and therefore
can make it into a detectable detectable
format
finally uh like i said that fellow is
assisted by jetta you
we also have a jet iu which is a web
server uh available.ijb.dress.n
where one can put in their sequence of
interest and the fellow the guides and
the
primers will be detect will be designed
uh
using this tool so where do we go from
now
uh as you can see that you know this is
still a little bit old it was from ma uh
from
from uh pretty pretty an early time
point there
the number of cases in india and across
the world
is is you know huge at the moment
and we still rely on the fact that there
is sample collection
and then rtp cr or other techniques
and then whether one can identify
whether a person is positive or negative
so we have come up with innovations
where
there might be a possibility to do the
fellow the test at home using the
minimum most of
requirements as you can see over here it
doesn't require equipment
simple workflow and early diagnosis this
test is also
ready uh for ip reasons i am not able to
show how we are doing this
but uh you know of course a home testing
can also have other ramifications
uh sometimes even going beyond
biological but more psychological and so
on
so all these things have to be taken
into consideration uh
before launching these kind of tests but
technically it is possible to you know
advance feluda
for doing home testing at some point
so with that i would like to thank all
of you uh
for giving me the opportunity to present
before you today and there are a large
number of people who
uh it's a big lab it's a relatively big
lab with a lot of collaborators
and we are very generously funded uh
including
also the mark youngs and the scientist
award last year
um and of course tata is our official
partner for taking this
kit we have licensed this technology uh
to tata
and the most important slide is actually
this
uh we kind of started working on on
covet 19 for feluda
at the end of january expecting that
this would become a pandemic
and by march we had a working prototype
uh by you know which was ready and by
may we could license that to tata sons
currently it is undergoing evaluatory uh
you know regulatory
evaluation and we hope to have this
done as quickly as possible hopefully by
by the end of this year
and all this work would not have been
possible uh
if you know we didn't have highly
dedicated and highly motivated and
passionate
individuals who are students post docs
technicians
and research assistants and so on
working full time
over the last three to four months or
even more
and spending all their time and energy
during this pandemic period
to come up with the technology that
might be useful
uh in detecting covet 19 and helping
people
so this uh work is actually dedicated to
all of them some of them turned covet
positive on the way
all of them are doing well of course but
you know
it shows a little bit about the strength
that the student community brings in
doing
good science and i'm really thankful to
all of them
for for the efforts that they have put
with that i would be uh i would like to
thank all of you and would be happy to
take any questions
that you might have thanks dave for
sharing exciting information about
falooda
and best species from mug for
commercialization of your test